in case you haven't noticed I've gotten
somewhat obsessed with doing as many
proofs of the Pythagorean theorem as I
can do so let's do one more and like how
all of these proofs start let's
construct ourselves a right triangle so
let's going to I'm going to construct it
so this hypotenuse sits on the bottom so
that's the hypotenuse of my right
triangle try to draw it as big as
possible so that we have space to work
with so that's going to be my hypotenuse
and then let's say that this is my the
longer side that's not the hypotenuse it
doesn't we could have two sides that are
equal but I'll just draw it so it looks
a little bit longer let's call that side
length a and then let's draw this side
right over here it has to be a right
triangle so maybe it goes right over
there that's side of length B let me
extend the length a a little bit so it
definitely looks like a right triangle
and this is our 90 degree angle so the
first thing that I'm going to do is take
this triangle and then rotate it
counterclockwise by 90 degrees so if I
rotate it counterclockwise by 90 degrees
I'm literally just going to rotate it
like that and draw another completely
congruent version of this one so I'm
going to rotate it by 90 degrees and if
I did that this the hypotenuse would
then sit straight up so I'm going to
drew my best attempt to draw it almost
to scale as much as I can eyeball it
this side of length a will now come out
will I look something like this well now
look something like this it'll actually
be parallel to this over here so let's
see let me see how well I could draw it
all I could draw it so this is a side of
length a and if we care this would be
ninety degrees the rotation between the
corresponding sides are just going to be
90 degrees in every case that's going to
be 90 degrees that's going to be 90
degrees now let me draw side B so it's
going to look something like something
like that or the length the side that's
length B and this and the right angle is
now here so all I did is I rotated
this by 90 degrees counterclockwise now
what I want to do is construct a
parallelogram I'm going to construct a
parallelogram by essentially and let me
label this so this is height C right
over here let me do it in that white
color this is height C now what I want
to do is go from this point and go up C
as well go up C go up C as well now so
this is height C as well and what is
this length what is the length over here
from this point to this point going to
be what is this length going to be well
a little clue is is this is a
parallelogram
I had this line right over here is going
to be parallel to this line it's
maintained the same distance and since
it's traveling the same distance in the
X direction or in the horizontal
direction and the vertical direction
this is going to be the same length so
this is going to be of length a now the
next question I have for you is what is
the area of this parallelogram
that I have just constructed well to
think about that let's redraw this part
of the diagram so that the parallelogram
is kind of sitting on the ground so this
is length a this is this is length a
this is length this is length C this is
length C and if you look at this part
right over here it gives you a clue the
height of the parallelogram there's this
green color the height of the
parallelogram is given right over here
this side is perpendicular is
perpendicular to the base so the height
of the parallelogram the height of the
parallelogram is a as well so what's the
area well the area of a parallelogram is
just the base times the height so the
area of this parallelogram right over
here is going to be a squared a squared
now let's do the same thing but let's
rotate our original right triangle let's
rotate it the other way so let's rotate
it 90
Gries clockwise and this time instead of
pivoting on this point we're going to
pivot on that point right over there so
what are we going to get so the side of
length see if we rotate it if we rotate
it like that it's going to end up right
over here try to draw it as close to
scale as possible so that side has
length C now the side of length B is
going to pop out look something like
this look something like this it's going
to be parallel to that this is going to
be a right angle so let me draw it like
that that looks pretty good and then the
side of length a the side of length a is
going to be out here the side of length
a is going to be right over here so
that's a and then this right over here
is B and I want to do that B in blue do
the B in blue and then this right angle
once we've rotated is just sitting right
over here now let's do the same exercise
let's construct a parallelogram right
over here so this is height C this is
height C as well so by the same logic we
used over here if this length is B this
length is B as well these are parallel
lines we're going the same distance in
the horizontal direction we're going the
same where rising the same in the
vertical direction we know that because
they're parallel so this is length B
down here this is length B up there now
what is the area of this parallelogram
right over there what is the area of
that parallelogram going to be well once
again to help us visualize it we can
draw it kind of sitting sitting on flat
so this is that side then you have
another side right over here they both
have length B and you have the sides of
length C so that's C that's C what is
its height well you see it right over
here its height its height has length B
as well it gives right there we know
that this is that this is 90 degrees
this is 90 degrees we did a 90 degree
rotation so this is how we constructed
the thing so given that the area of a
parallelogram is just the base times the
height base times the height the area of
this parallelogram is B squared so now
things now things are starting to get
interesting now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to copy and paste this this
part right over here
because this is in my in my mind the
most interesting part of our diagram let
me see how well I can how well I can
select it so let me select this part
right over here so let me copy and then
I am going to scroll down and then let
me paste it let me paste it so this
diagram that we've constructed right
over here it's pretty clear what the
area of it is the combined diagram now
let me let me delete a little few parts
of it just so that whoops I want to do
that in black so that it cleans it up so
let me clean this thing up so we really
get the part that we want to focus on so
cleaning that up cleaning and cleaning
this up cleaning this up all right over
there so it what is and actually let me
let me delete this right down here as
well let me delete this right over here
although we know that this length was C
and actually I'll draw it right over
here this is from our original
construction we know that this length is
C we know this height is C we know this
down here is C but my question for you
is what is the area of this combined
what is the area of this combined shape
well it's just a squared plus B squared
let me write that down the area it's
just a squared plus B squared the area
of those two parallelograms now how can
we express how can we maybe rearrange
pieces of this shape so that we can
express it in terms of C well it might
have jumped out at you when I drew this
or when I drew this line right over here
we know that this is a
length I want to do that in white we
know we know that this part right over
here is of length C this comes from our
original construction whoops
lost my diagram this is of length C
that's of length C and then this right
over here is of length C and so what we
could do is take this top right triangle
which is completely congruent to our
original right triangle and shift it
down so remember the entire including
this top right triangle is a squared
plus B squared
and what we're cluding this part down
here which is our original triangle but
what happens if we or take that so let
me cut let me actually cut and then let
me paste it and all I'm doing is I'm
moving that triangle down here so now it
looks like this
so I've just rearranged the area that
was a squared B squared so this entire
area of this entire square is still a
squared but plus B squared a squared is
this entire area right over here it was
before a parallelogram I just shifted
that top part of the parallelogram down
B squared is this entire area is this
entire area right over here
well what's this going to be in terms of
C well we know that this entire thing is
a C by C square so the area in terms of
C is just C squared
so a squared plus B squared is equal to
C squared and we have once again proven
the Pythagorean theorem